rogan joe rogan comes up to me and goes
i want you to do my podcast
yeah and then i'm like yeah he's like
i'd really love you whenever i go let's
do it
okay i still haven't been on it why
don't you follow up with him
am i supposed to text joe and go hey can
i be i don't want to
why why because i asked you i'm curious
yeah because i'll tell you why
okay is is that people that do our
podcast
i ask them
people ask yeah and then they follow up
like
not through me um
i feel like i feel like you know i've
known joe for 20 years
yeah i love joe rogan he's the best
okay but there is he's an alpha male
okay and i'm a coward false
oh i really am i really i literally am
weak
and i'm a follower you think you're
sheep
no but like you know but i've talked
about this back in the tribe days when
we lived in tribes i'd be a gatherer for
sure i'd be gathering [ __ ] that
i don't even own you know being stealing
yeah people would be go hunting is that
one of the guys
that's not a gathering stealing no
stealing stealing gathering
that's not the same it is the same thing
it's not no
listen the people in the village would
go out and they hunt
right and i'd be weaving baskets with
the women
and making clogs and making sure that
the haystacks are nice
interesting right and then i'd be
gathering other things and
every once in a while i gather other
people's stuff because i'm so good at
what i do
so when they came come back from the
hunt they're like hey dude where's my
water moccasins
i go oh damn i got it wait a water
moccasin is a snake
it's not shoes
what if they have a [ __ ] hey bro went
back to my apartment what if my snakes
are gone who took my snake
what if he has a pet snake a watermelon
snake water moccasin is his
name like the everglades the swampy area
you could turn them into shoes moccasins
it's just not waterproof
yeah here's another thing okay i've also
been thinking about
this as is that
there is no time period in human
civilization
that i would have survived in
any any any civilization where there's a
plague
i i'm the first one to get it i know it
well that's if you're a poor person
no i'll just be even if i was in a regal
like situation i would just have
blotches on my face
and people like hey dude what's going on
i go i don't know and then i'd die and
then they would name
the disease effort we're gonna call it
like legionnaires yeah he got the water
disease yeah slip
blotch he's got slept botches blotches
yeah
and then like um back when in the
frontier days
remember back in the frontier days with
abe lincoln
right i've been thinking about this um
imagine having a family
and then the nearest log cabin is five
miles away
so i have to hunt for the food right
i would probably leave
and come back with like a cricket and a
bat wing
that's hard to find i know that that's
like all i could get it's really good
actually and then when i get back
home a new family's living there
dang and i'm going to be like where are
my kids am i
that was three years ago
right and i'm like show for it it took a
batwing in the creek
right they'd be dead so if you had to
choose an
era now no
aside from today oh aside from today
from today actually nothing
before or nothing after um 1900
nothing after night i would have to can
i be born
in a certain regal family i guess you
can you can choose well then i would be
like in the ming dynasty and i would be
like
a king you'd be emperor for sure yeah
but if i had to be a common person
uh what society
um probably
i would probably live on an island like
an island like
an island kind of a society and about
what's happening like have mammals
um you know evolved and live on land now
are you still like
you know what i mean like prehistoric
are you like prisoners you can you don't
have to follow when humans actually
you can be any time or if there were no
other humans i would
be dead because i would need other
people to do the work for me
oh right so i would probably be a part
of a society a clan
where they all know that i'm the
[ __ ] one
like he ain't gonna do nothing right and
because they love me so much they still
feed me
and i i could still roam with them
yeah i would roam you know the
wilderness with them or whatever but i
would be the last guy
you know i mean i would be a problem for
everybody i think um
yeah you kala maybe like
ancient mesopotamia of course treasure
[ __ ] treasure hunter
maybe when like the code of hammurabi
was first written
you know the first set of laws i would
have liked to been like inject my own
like hey can this be a law
like some absurd thing